there was a uh
there's a couple fights over the weekend
did you guys see
i didn't watch the fights i saw
highlights though yeah that's all you
needed yeah this one was the least i've
never been less interested in a trailer
fight usually they're good at spectacle
and like having this kind of like i have
to watch this whatever it is yeah and
this time i was like nah there wasn't
someone to pull you in no and holyfield
apparently was the last second fill in
too
it was supposed to be oscar versus vitor
belfort and i think oscar would have
pulled some casuals in yes i don't know
if it if it does what jake paul does or
something like that or like even like
holy fields or whatever but not
holyfield um mike tyson and uh roy jones
but i think oscar is a big enough name
but let's see if oscar still got it
right and uh
but what was interesting was
um
anderson silva fought yeah and he fought
ortiz and he knocked out t ortiz and it
almost looked like
scripted the way they knocked him out
but
the way that tito went down it seemed
very legit like he seemed like truly
concussed did you guys see that i did i
didn't see the naga no i didn't but um
it sets up a really interesting fight
i think anderson silva versus jake paul
do you think so i'll tell you why he
wants it yeah yeah they all do i'll tell
you why though
anderson's i i think jake paul is smart
to continue to fight mma guys yeah
absolutely
because it enrages the mma community and
he needs animosity for
the interests yeah
he has to do the mayweather thing where
people are paying to see the guy loose
yeah right
i think that he'll eventually get more
and more fans that want to see him win
and knock these people out but a lot of
people are going to watch these fights
because they want to see him get his ass
kicked yeah
and
anderson
when he was the best fighter in the
[ __ ] world i think beats anybody but
now he's what 48
or something 46.
he's up there but he's a nice [ __ ]
boxer he just beat julio cesar chavez jr
okay like who was it was a pretty legit
boxer in his day
so
i think what jake needs to do is
continue
picking away at mma guys and anderson
has enough legacy anderson has enough
popularity anderson has enough support
in the mma community but he also has the
boxing pedigree where people be like
okay this is gonna be the mma guy to
take out jake and this way he can
continue to drive the wedge with the ufc
he gets to talk all the [ __ ] he wants
about dana white and fighter pay and all
that other stuff i'm gonna give anderson
silva his biggest payday ever just like
i gave tyron his biggest baby really
enrage the mma community which is the
strongest community in fight sports
right now get them all to support
anderson silver every one of those
fighters that came up watching anderson
silva thinking he was the greatest
fighter that's ever existed there was a
time where i think he [ __ ] won like
10 fights in a row so like he was just
unbelievable in his heyday i think
that is the next fight to make for jake
and similar height and weight they are
similar height and weight that's the
thing now we're getting into it's not
like he's taking advantage of like a
smaller nice green small guy tyler
woodley smaller than jake but anderson's
over six to 185
now jake probably walks around over two
anderson will [ __ ] him up and that's
what we need people to think i was just
watching the highlight of how he caught
him yeah great head movement i mean just
came around counter hook like that was
impressive and comfortable yeah it looks
like more boxing than an mma fighter way
more that was impressive yeah yeah yeah
really comfortable in the pocket which i
think could be dangerous for jake
because he's able to take advantage of
mma guys and not being comfortable in
the pocket because if it's an mma fight
you only need some part of the fist to
touch your head and you're going down
yeah so there isn't a lot of that bob
and weaving like you're seeing in there
whereas boxing it's like you got your
gloves kind of covering up you can move
around
i'm just saying that to me
i think jake [ __ ] boxers don't fight
tommy fury don't fight any of the boxers
fight mma guys with big enough names
pedigrees and resumes where the whole
mma community is behind them
and let that drive the [ __ ] i don't
think he wants anderson silva though i i
agree it's a tough fight
that's a tough fight
[ __ ] him you had to go rounds with tyler
woodley
who's you know he's a decent striker but
like not amazing yeah anderson silva i
think could he got him but he's older
he's 48 is he 48 at 46. of course 46. to
me he looked old and that's where i was
like i don't know man i don't know if
he's going to hold up he just looked old
mm-hmm and the the punch is great but
also who's he fighting tito ortiz he's
not a boxer is he he was an mma guy also
right yeah i know to me
i don't know [ __ ] it seemed like a
lateral move in the sense that like all
right you fought one mma guy who can
kind of fight this one's a better
striker but also much older and it
seemed like a lateral move in that sense
yeah the challenge
i think needs to seem a little bit
bigger for me to see him interested and
maybe anderson silver will do it maybe
you guys will convince me by the time
the fight rolls around i'll buy it again
i think if you were a bigger mma fan
yeah that's the thing is these mma i was
looking at the [ __ ] story as i was
researching and these fans were like uh
this is gonna be the guy to knock out j
and it's like every single fight this
guy i can't wait till this guy knocks
out jake they are just dying and they're
so sure every next guy that gets brought
up is gonna knock out jake paul and they
want it to happen so badly yeah and to
your point that's what's gonna make
money monetize that feeling got it yeah
you can't people can't people aren't
going to buy a fight they're kind of
interested in seeing the outcome up yeah
yeah yeah you want to see [ __ ]
get knocked out you're buying this yeah
you have to be emotionally invested for
50 bucks yeah that's not nothing yes yes
yes yes yes how good is anderson silva's
english
he pretended to not speak english back
in the day right i think he wouldn't
have to do the [ __ ] talk with like
chelsea he's actually yeah he can speak
english he's good could he should talk
with jake to build a fight so he's an
interesting one because he's never
really been a [ __ ] talker that's what
i'm saying well but he also trolls big
time
so he trolls in the fight but i think
before he's capable of doing as well
so like
yeah i don't know i
again you you want him to be able to
help build the hype for the fight he's
going to have more genuine interest than
tyron but tyron the week of the fight
really
[ __ ] i wasn't interested until the
week of earned his money yep he earned
his money he murdered it so what is
anderson going to do to build it up
right he's not going to tap into any
like racial division right because while
he's a black dude he's a black dude from
brazil and they have their own
kind of like colorism thing going on
yeah um so that's not going to be
something that maybe he's not going to
go all black lives matter on jake paul
or all why are you trying to be hip-hop
or something like that
his issues are completely detached from
that yeah so this is gonna be like
there's gonna be he's gonna have to
really pretend to go i wanna beat him
for the mma community yeah so you put
the respect on strikers from the and i
don't even know if he feels that i think
he's just like i'm 46 i'm trying to make
a few million before i uh finish this
fighting [ __ ] and then also how big is
that is that like uh audience you're
tapping into versus someone else that
can just tap into yo i want to smash you
like on some racial [ __ ] like on some
other things like his name and me the
name is baby yeah maybe me because i was
all had ufc right like he was the
biggest thing yeah when you were doing
probably when you were doing martial
arts yeah he
the defense was [ __ ] phenomenal yeah
yeah
i'm thinking from jake's perspective
he's like he's a good fighter he's got
hands he's like a champion
it's risky and he might not bring much
he's not going to bring a ton like let
me fight a [ __ ] another basketball
tomato yeah like crazy thing and i'll
give this up to you
isn't this the [ __ ]
about that trump was announcing
yes the holyfield one
but i mean this is just in the santa fe
yeah yeah yeah no one's talking about
that [ __ ] what's talking about
like jake paul has a bigger troll than
the ex-president
why are you giving it up to me what did
i say no just because you said like jake
paul's the biggest draw okay
that's crazy i had this thought too
that's crazy
might be saving boxing
yeah because not even that just i think
mma as it got more and more popular they
looked at boxing as like it's this thing
we can all do it
jake paul is proving you can take elite
mma not necessarily strikers but elite
mma fighters put them in a boxing ring
and then a disney star who's been
training at boxing for three years yeah
can kick the [ __ ] out of them yeah i
think maybe maybe we were doing with
brendan that i was saying that or
something like oh yeah but you're a
hundred percent right anderson was like
i have to i'm taking the art of boxing
so seriously like they're realizing how
different it is it's not like oh we do
everything i kick your ass in a boxing
match yeah yeah yeah i think connor and
floyd we all knew floyd is gonna win but
some people thought connor would and now
we're like yo it's not even the best in
the world it's not even the best ever
it's a [ __ ] disney store who puts out
youtube videos but it's trained for
three years can beat an mma guy
yeah elite mma fighters exactly so when
you're training for me when you say
you're saving boxing it's not like um
you're bringing attention to boxing it's
you're putting respect putting skill
yeah you're re-establishing respect for
the support that was kind of starting to
get forgotten as like a second tier uh
ufc they do everything these guys can
box who gives a [ __ ] yeah yeah and now
it's like not boxing is a different
animal it's not something that's just
part of the mma package it is its own
skill and if you do not train it by
itself when fighting somebody within
that discipline you will lose
even if they have far less fight
experience
uh than you like way less it doesn't
even matter it is its own specific skill
it's got to be it's kind of pretty cool
yeah it just needs to have like the
infrastructure and personalities that
the ufc does and they just do that so
[ __ ] brilliantly yeah it's really
amazing
you